Okay, right. Um, now,
um, we have rural settlements and urban settlements okay,
we'll start with rural settlements
looking at the size hierarchy,
um looking at the pattern
looking at the shape
looking at the
uh issues okay,
so that's the four things that we gonna look at here
and then we'll head on to urban settlements
do the same thing um,
so that is uh basically
um how we categorize settlement okay,
so first of all in terms of function okay,
rural areas or rural settlements are single
we say that they are unifunctional
or they have a single function okay,
what do we mean by that?
You'll only find one type of economic activity here
or you find one sector here
which is the primary sector
you'll only find primary activities
so you get agriculture
er in the rural areas so agriculture is practice er
to to to to any living uh fishing the fishing industry,
forest tree,
uh so on and so on okay,
so these are like activities from the primary sector
okay, we talked about these in the
uh economic geograph okay,
so that's why we are say that they are
they are uni functional
you not find secondary
you not find factories in royal settlement
you not going to find tertiary activities
service providers there
so you'll only find um
primary activities
only primary activity
that's why there it is uni
Uni means one single
only primary activities
no second or no tertiary okay
Whereas in the urban areas
er you'll find er
multiple multiple activities
types of activities
you'll find factories,
you'll find shops,
transport so on and so on so as you can see er
there's multiple sectors that you're going to get
in the urban settlements okay,
so that's why we say that they are multifunctional okay,
because there's more than one sector that is er
practice okay,
right so let's look at the patterns now so the patterns
so it's the uh settlement
look at the patterns start with the patterns
then the shapes then the size okay,
right, so the patterns start with the patterns
so we have two types of patterns then okay,
er two types of patterns
and the patterns is basically in terms of proximity
okay, er by proximity how close
are are your houses or property
er how close are they
er to each other? Okay,
so if they are far away from each other
we say that it is dispatched
it is a dispatched pattern okay,
but if they are close to er
to each other where you have one
one property close to the next
as you can see here
then we say that it is nucleated okay,
so that is the patterns that we're talking about
so we have two types of dispersed pattern
far away when properties are
or houses are far away from each other are mucated okay,
settlement in which houses are close
Together okay,
so of course,
er what does it mean for the people there?
Er, if we are far away from each other
er what does it mean for us?
Okay, because er
we are far away from each other usually
er when you have this is like for an example
er isolated hamster er
isolated farmstead or a hamlet okay,
where you have a very few houses
or an isolated hamster farmstead where you have
one individual house
that is in that area okay,
so of course that means that we are far away from
from schools
government cannot build a school next to you because er
er since you are alone there okay,
government offers schools to areas where there is er
a threshold population that they need we need
this amount of students for us to build a school okay,
because there's a er
a very very low population um
here you cannot find services
so basic services,
uh far away because um
for an example shops
how can you support a shop when you just want family
okay, so that's why it's far away from basic services
okay, um and um
it produces large yields or or or um
or basically um
you get high economic gains because you are alone
you probably own a very huge farm okay,
and so of course that means as yield
there's large yield means production okay,
so large production
you are producing a lot,
many fruits if you are Selling fruits,
many veg, veggies,
if you are selling veggies in that particular season,
cause you own,
you don't have to share your land with anyone.
You are alone,
you own the vast amount of land
requires large amounts of money to practice farming. Yes,
er, because this is a large, er,
a large land, of course,
that means you're going to have to put a lot of inputs,
okay? And um,
like inputs
like you need water,
irrigation, er,
you need nutrients,
you going to buy nutrients, er,
you're going to buy, er,
fertilizers,
er, supplements,
so on and so on
you going to need, er, er,
er, you going to work a lot, okay,
you going to need people,
er, er, so there's a lot of work
and there's a lot of capital that is being put in there,
a lot of work because this is huge ground. Um,
so it makes sense
why it requires large amounts of money,
you're not sharing it,
you're just alone
and so that's a lot of money that you need, er,
to practice farming on that large land. Okay,
considering that you are, er,
er, very few individuals in that house
or just what
require as a safety and securities
because you are alone,
of course, er, um,
we know why, um,
we, we, especially in the past few years,
um, even back then
you'll find out thieves would look out for farms, okay,
because they know that they are isolated Uh,
there's just one guy there that lives there
so they can uh,
take advantage of that
okay. And so,
um, usually a lot of safety and security risk, high risk
there's less contact and less social
socializing
cannot socialize just alone
especially in an isolated farm state um,
there's no immediate response in case of emergencies
K usually you're far away from those services
from a police station
maybe police station is there and you are there and um,
it's very difficult to get a response
when you need an ambulance
ambulance has to travel um,
um create a lands
greater distances to reach you okay,
so those are advantages
and some of them are disadvantages okay,
so it's mixed guys okay.
And then um,
when you talk
nucleated patterns,
nucleated patterns close to each other okay,
er first of
so it lacks privacy, okay,
because you are close to
to each other okay,
so what is happening in that house
you can hear it
I mean that
when you are there
the neighbour
okay, that is so
so you lack privacy okay.
Um, there's a sharing of equipment okay,
so you don't have to buy
um equipment
this is a disadvantage to um,
but it can be advantage in some way
it's an it disadvantage to dispersed
settlements because
they have to er
dish out a lot of money in order to buy equipment
because they are alone okay,
but as nucleated uh,
settlements
we can just crowdfund Okay,
put together money
and we buy, uh,
farming equipment. Okay.
Um, it can be advantageous for dispersed
settlement because,
um, when you have,
when you are the only one that is using that,
that is using your equipment,
that means that
the low maintenance cost,
cause if you give someone else your tools,
someone else might
damage them and so you'd have to pay. So for the,
for it. So it is an advantage in that perspective. Okay.
Uh, so it's safe.
Of course it's safe. Um,
because you guys,
like there's many of you. So,
um, that, that's much safer,
you know, and you're not just alone and vulnerable,
uh, purchases small yields and has limited economy gains
because there's a lot of you guys,
you guys have to share,
er, this, er, particular land.
Okay, share, fragment it,
share it, er,
and so of course you wouldn't get,
you wouldn't make as much money as the,
as this guy is making because he owns that whole land
and you own just a patch of this land.
Uh, this independent, uh,
the, the independent decision making is limited. Okay,
when you decide,
you can't just decide alone.
It's a democracy.
Everyone has to vote.
Everyone has to have their,
um, their decision or their suggestion head.
So it's limited in terms of independent decision.